it's Hillary Clinton itching for a
rematch president Trump attacking
Clinton on Twitter over her emails and
taunting her to enter the 2020 race
Clinton firing right back saying don't
tempt me do your job but Hillary's just
joking right well maybe not take a look
you know it truly is remarkable how
obsessed he remains with me nothing has
been more examined and looked at than my
emails we all know that so he's either
lying or delusional or both maybe there
does need to be a rematch I mean
obviously I can beat him again here we
go again I can beat him again I mean
that's not an obsession that is a
delusion that one holds to keep out the
reality and I don't blame her I mean
it's she's probably had to say these
kind of things being married to a man
who's bedded more women than my pillow
by the way you know she's not immune to
this Ukraine stuff she enters the if she
enters this picture that's gonna stain
her as well what do you think about the
chin do you think that she just does it
she's on a book tour so it doesn't hurt
to have a little sure attention she's
like a celebrity stalker you know you're
gonna find her outside the white house
at midnight telling the Secret Service
if you just let me and I can talk to him
why he wants to talk to me but I think
right now she's still going back to the
emails and says everything was examined
except for the 33,000 that she
acid-washed could you imagine if shift
subpoenas Trump for one of his emails
just one and he acid washes just one and
then says it was about golf could you
imagine what the reaction would be and
she did that to 33,000 it's a huge huge
double standard then lastly if she does
get in here's what she's looking at
she's looking at Joe who looks like
toast right now she's looking at Bernie
who's now has to coast because of
herself her only opponent is Liz Warren
and she's got to say to herself guys
look at this I beat Trump in the popular
vote uh out raised him I out debated him
I can beat him again if I just go to
Wisconsin and I promise I will put Liz
Warren on the ticket and I will put
Bernie in the cabinet let's have a
rematch and that's convincing to some
Democrats I don't know why me we have a
second topic we want to get to so we'll
just get a quick hit on this one from
you well I think this is a wonderful GOP
fantasy she's the whipping boy how long
has she been demonized by
publicans so she makes a silly comment
you know again I think to Jinnah
publicity police she didn't call anybody
deplorable even eyes for her own
wrongdoing she just I don't I don't buy
it I mean to me
Trump is obsessed with her because she
beat him in the popular vote he's always
saying he's upset with the popular vote
that's why he says oh no Hillary Clinton
and the Obama administration for making
her push untrue talking points after the
Benghazi attack do you remember this it
began spontaneously in Benghazi was in
fact initially a spontaneous reaction
what sparked the recent violence was the
airing on the Internet of a very hateful
very offensive video in a new book rice
recalls a conversation she had with her
mom about Clinton quote why do you have
to go on the shows where is Hillary well
I think that Hillary is wiped after a
brutal week I said she was unrelenting I
smell a rat this is not a good idea
can't you get out of it Hillary was
nowhere to be seen and we all we talked
about this a lot we always wonder what
happened why did Susan Rice have to go
out there and say that yeah I remember
it as if it was like four years ago five
years ago but I do think that it brings
up a comparison that I've said before
there's so many people back then that
were laughing about Benghazi who are
wetting their pants over the Ukrainian
phone call there's no comparison for
Americans good point we talked about it
four years ago years ago I was out on
the streets to say what do you think
about Benghazi and they used to say
who's mr. Guses no she was the Patsy and
they left her holding the bag and they
had to cover up for the fact that there
was a terror attack two months before
the election after they had campaigned
on defeating al Qaeda and the truth was
is that the administration didn't
protect their ambassador on the
anniversary of 9/11 in a country they
had just toppled and then after a year
of security requests so they blamed a
video guy when it was actually their
fault and we still don't know what
really happened
because they did they did they fight
some subpoenas I think they fought a few
subpoenas back then you know this isn't
imagine I don't think there been any
investigations I don't think anybody had
to go up the Capitol and testify I don't
think Republicans wore this out and
Jesse still but it's pretty interesting
wall and always is about a Jedidiah time
we you know all these years later now
Susan Rice is basically saying I took
the fall for Hillary Clinton yeah on the
day that Hillary Clinton puts a little
Chum in the water about running in 2020
right a meeting in there she's saying
well I don't think Hillary set me up
although my mom did okay so your mom but
obviously yeah they put her out there
front and center she didn't have the
right story and it really derailed her
whole career I mean any aspiration she
had from that point on she was it was
destroyed she was completely destroyed
in the media universally pretty much on
both sides at one point and Hillary
Clinton had to do it because she didn't
want to take the fall for that she had
already been perceived as a liar I know
you don't think so but on many issues
including her emails and it would have
been that would have been over for her
so they said who could we throw out
there Hillary's busy getting a mani-pedi
can you go out there and you know do
this match so she was exhausted after a
brutal we have